mississauga la grande banlieue de
toronto sept cent mille habitants 18
mille entreprises ici seulement 40% de
la population à l'anglais comme langue
maternelle
les six circonscriptions que compte la
ville ont voté en bloc aux deux
dernières élections fédérales libéral en
2015 conservateurs quatre ans plus tôt
nous sommes allé sonder l'humeur des
électeurs dans ces immenses tours
d'habitation tout près de l'hôtel de
ville circonscription mississauga centre
le vote à mississauga est assez
indicatif du vote qu' on va voir en
général au canada donc ça vous les
partis politiques surveille mississauga
souvent dans les sondages c'est un des
circonscriptions qui sont souvent isolés
analysé microdoses parce qu'on veut
comprendre un peu la logique de cet
électeur à l'ap au 28ème étage pierre et
sa femme monica d'origine mexicaine sont
dans la jeune quarantaine tous les deux
ingénieurs chimistes
ils ont deux petites filles l'emploi les
droits des femmes les services publics
c'est ce qui les intéresse avant tout
dans cette campagne électorale
les révélations sur les déguisements
blackface de justin trudeau les ont-ils
choqué somos coeur dans les hôtels que
la paille
[Rires]
non en fait je suis plus scandalisé par
l'appel du parti vert parce qu'elle sait
actuelle tandis que le black fait soyaux
longtemps s'ils sont globalement
satisfaits des quatre ans du
gouvernement libéral leur vote relève
plus de la stratégique de la conviction
de réfléchir un peu encore médias cercle
main qui vous ne voudrez pas
voir le suivre au 11e étage
nancy et wafiq 43 et 55 ans sont venus
d'egypte
l architecte lui optométristes ils sont
scandalisés par les prix de l'immobilier
par les taxes qu'ils jugent bien trop
élevé ce qui compte le plus pour eux
poutine gonnehem tout d'un paquet selon
le sociologue fuyuki cours à sawa les
prix des logements qui explosent
c'est une question centrale pour les
électeurs dans toute la région du grand
toronto
si parti libéral n'adresse pas les dons
les intérêts par deux portefeuilles
pratico pratique beaucoup d'électeurs à
toronto auront ça va leur coûter parce
que c'est un pivot justement pour le
parti conservateur monsieur scheer a
multiplié les annonces ce sujet pinault
à nancy au ficg n'ont pas encore décidé
à qui ils vont donner leur vote mais il
désapprouve fortement l'inaction du
gouvernement libéral face à la spirale
inflationniste à l'aller un retraité de
84 ans qui habite au 8e étage avec sa
femme d'origine australienne veut donner
sa chance à andrew scheer et le parti
conservateur a lancé au 11e étage sa
droite et sayed sont originaires du
pakistan
elle a une petite entreprise lui est
mécanicien automobile leurs deux enfants
c'est ce qu'ils ont de plus précieux
les fusillades qui se sont multipliées
dans la région les inquiète au plus haut
point
malgré l'insécurité croissante à ses
yeux sa droite se dit une libérale
inconditionnel ce n'est pas le cas de
son mari
ils blâment le parti libéral pour s'être
traîné des pieds dans le dossier des
armes à feu entre autres comme toulouse
hommes perdent ou des noirs c'est par ce
conservateur par d'investir davantage
dans les services policiers
donc pour essayer de sécuriser certains
quartiers sont plus problématiques à
toronto
mais dans la grande région torontoise
les gens sont plutôt en faveur d'un
contrôle d'armes à feu sas a pu
favoriser le parti libéral s'il est
capable de capitaliser sur cette
question là est de montrer que monsieur
cher peut-être n'adresse pas justement
ce type les causes fondamentales du
problème